I've been living with a shadow
overhead Drew Barrymore was in that film
with me and I don't think she'd mind me
saying her singing is just horrendous
well Drew could tell Hugh Grant her
response oh you Bert or she could sing
it all I wanna do is Find A Way Back
Into Love we are quite different yeah
remember when these two fell for each
other in music and lyrics just a little
bit louder because this song is intended
for humans I'm in musical uh Dead Zone I
have no no music in my soul so I'm
incredibly badly cast in this film Hugh
looks back on the rom-com for Wired
[Music]
telling his Dungeons and Dragons
co-stars Chris Pine and Michelle
Rodriguez that Drew's voice left a lot
to be desired I'm auto-tuned a bit but
um not as much as some I I Drew
Barrymore was in that film with me and I
don't think she'd mind me saying her
singing is just horrendous
I've heard dogs oh snap spark better
than she sings I likely he's a very very
nice person in the wake of Hugh's
comments Drew goes to the gram with her
response
[Music]
is
a few bars of their on-screen duet
[Music]
oh Hugh Bert Hubert that's for you now
of course Hugh admits they both needed
help in the singing department and Drew
she came out on top but having said that
once they tuned her up she sounded way
better than me because she's got heart
and voice and rock and roll whereas I
sounded like Julie Andrews and I'm meant
to be kind of rock and roll as well I'm
auto-tuned beyond belief well I love
auto tune I'd like to marry autism and
when E.T was withdrew and Hugh in 2007
the Stars gushed over one another it was
an extraordinary feat of acting
um and he sings beautifully contrary to
what he says
setting aside time
to clear a little space in the corners
of my mind
all I wanna do is
you did say to me on one of our first
rehearsals oh God they warned me about
you and I think what you were referring
to was my bubbliness and optimism and
absolute can-do positivity Pollyanna
like annoying sickening sweet
mellifluous happiness
the exact antithesis of me you would
invent Drew Barrymore back to 2023 is
Drew manifesting another duet on the
Drew Barrymore show she tells you in the
caption join me ironically he's a very
very nice person and a very good friend
contrary to all the things he's saying
what a lovely person you are Hubert oh
Hugh Bert Hubert that's for you
[Music]
yeah foreign